the scientific Community is not really
eager to this day to talk about this
topic or debate it they are in the U.S
being forced to talk about it and debate
it because they're being pulled in front
of a congressional committee this is a
report that was put out by the select
subcommittee on the coronavirus pandemic
uh called the proximal origin of a
cover-up did the Bethesda boys downplay
a lab leak again here in the U.S we're
looking at this that this is for very
much in a partisan lens so Republicans
control the house this is a house
controlled committee nonetheless they've
got access to real documents that the
rest of us were not able to have access
to at this point and that's what we're
going to go through uh now a little bit
this is from their executive summary uh
their kind of bottom line here is that
this this is the proximal Origins paper
which we'll talk about what that is in
just a second is one of the single most
impactful and influential scientific
papers in history and it expressed
conclusions that were not based on sound
science nor in fact but instead on
assumptions the question is why so that
was the frame that they went into this
with and this is the paper that they are
referencing the proximal origin of
sarskov 2 published March 17 2020
there's this number of logical gaps in
the argument of the paper
and that that makes it not very
persuasive and anyone who
sort of knows what they're talking about
can start to pick up on those gaps and
what we've seen I think since we last
spoke with some of these documents that
we're about to get into is that the
authors of the paper were keenly aware
of these logical leaps as well and so
the question becomes how did and why did
this paper start with a certain
conclusion and end up somewhere much
different and the the first thing that
we can look at
is this email on January 31st from
Christian Anderson he's the lead author
of the paper he's writing to Anthony
fauci this is before the paper this is
kind of what kicked off the creation of
the paper and he writes here about that
he's looked at this sequence he's looked
at the genetic sequence of the virus and
that the on when you look closely the
unusual features of the virus make up a
really small part of the genome so one
has to look really closely to see that
some of the features look potentially
engineered then Anderson goes on to say
in his testimony and elsewhere that
fauci then encouraged him if he thinks
that there's something strange here to
start looking into this question and and
putting a paper together uh this we now
have access to some of the earlier
drafts of the paper the paper came out
it was officially published in March
this is from February 1st so this is
like the first draft of the paper and he
says uh or the authors say it is
impossible to distinguish whether this
strange fear and cleavage site was
gained uh due to Evolution or passage
and by passage they've been kind of
continually infecting animals in the lab
to increase the you know
transmissibility or whatever of the
virus and the data is consistent with
either scenario so that was the first
draft if we jump to the final draft here
the conclusion is since we observed all
notable SARS Cove 2 features including
the optimized RBD and polybasic cleavage
site in related coronaviruses in nature
we do not believe that any type of
laboratory based scenario is plausible
so they went from it's impossible to
tell to the the end uh here is that
any kind of laboratory based scenario
whether it's engineering or you know
passing through mice over and over again
is not plausible at all and the question
that this group is trying to get to is
how did how did that process work what
what what was it the you know normal
scientific inquiry that led you there or
was there pressure coming in and one of
the emails they highlighted was this one
between Christian Anderson and the
editor of nature magazine what would
ultimately be published saying that
um you know admitting that this was
prompted by Tony fauci Francis Collins
Jeremy Ferrer who was a colleague in the
UK
um and uh this is so you know the the
committee points to this is kind of like
here that this proves right here that
fauci from the very beginning you know
created this paper and he did so for a
certain reason I want to quickly play uh
Christian Anderson's response to that uh
in his Congressional testimony and then
get you to weigh in on all of that Matt
and and tell me you know what what to
make of all this
when I outlined my initial hypothesis
about a potentially engineered virus Dr
fault she told me and I'm paraphrasing
here if you think this virus came from a
lab you should write a scientific paper
about it
not only is this not a prompt to
disprove the lab League Theory it was
specifically predicated on our initial
hypothesis of a lab-associated virus
the allegations that Dr fauci prompted
the drafting a proximal origin to
disprove the lab leak is quote mined
from an email I wrote to participants of
the February 1 conference call
the scientific method is based on two
basic concepts of one formulating
hypotheses and two testing those
hypotheses Often by trying to disprove
them my initial hypothesis was a lab
Theory
when I stated that we were trying to
disprove any type of lab Theory I was
specifically referring to us testing our
early hypothesis
this is textbook science in action
what's your reaction to that was do you
believe that Anderson was kind of in a
good faith way just trying to follow the
scientific method and that is how this
conclusion was ultimately reached
no I'm afraid I don't
um I corresponded with Christian
Anderson at the time he gave no
indication that he was considering a lab
leak as even a possibility
I think it's worth just going back to
the timeline and and working out what
happens you're quite right to to show
that Christian Anderson raised with Tony
fauci the possibility that this virus
was engineered
in on the 31st of January uh 2020. and
he wasn't the only one raising this
query because Jeremy Farah at the
welcome trust in the UK was talking to
Eddie Holmes in Australia and Robert
Gary was joining in and uh Andrew Rambo
in Edinburgh basically
um uh as as Farah recounts in a book
that he's written
um these guys were saying 60 40 80 20 50
50 we think this was engineered
and that's why everyone was Raising this
with fauci and saying there needs to be
a conversation about how we deal with
this possibility
and that conversation indeed took place
on the 1st of February the Saturday
as we now know
um and
um sorry let me just pause there and go
back to Christian Anderson's remark
about the scientific method as it's
supposed to be done if you have that
concern why not share it with the world
he never indicated that he even thought
that and nor did any of those other
authors
until
uh
further information came to light many
months later he never said in February
March or indeed even April 2020 by the
way we did look at whether it was
potentially engineered because we
couldn't figure out a way in which that
fearing cleavage site had been inserted
added to the genome unless by
engineering it didn't look natural
Robert Gary was very explicit on that
point he said it doesn't look I can't
think of an evolutionary mechanism by
which that could have been added so
um and and over the following days after
that conference call Christian Anderson
makes some really very good arguments as
to why we need to keep considering this
lab-based scenario in private but he
never breathes any of this in public
now after the conference call on
Saturday February the 1st
um uh the the the the the the the on the
conference call were two Dutch
scientists Ron foucher and Marion
coopman's who argued strongly
that
it was a mistake to even consider this
possibility
one of the reasons they gave was because
it might open a Pandora's box of
speculating about the origin of other
pandemics including Ebola
that's effectively a sort of warning you
know watch it chaps this might this
might rebound on you
and interestingly though the the uh and
these two knew a lot more about
coronavirus biology than Christian
Anderson did Eddie Holmes knew quite a
lot but but Gary and Anderson were
basically Ebola experts not not uh
coronavirus experts there's one name by
the way which who wasn't on the meeting
and should have been a new Pharma back
coronavirus biology than any of these
people and that's Ralph Barrick in North
Carolina who somehow seems to have
stayed well clear of this whole process
but that's another interesting question
anyway the the point is that after that
as a result of that phone call it was
agreed that Anderson would draft a paper
and the original suggestion was as
indeed he said in that testimony that it
should consider the lab leak
and the evidence for and against it
but fuchsiers and coopmans
strong view that this was going to be a
mistake comes through in subsequent
emails
and they then got very upset by the way
when their arguments were suddenly
adopted into Anderson's draft without
their names appearing and
um meanwhile we have fauci and Farah and
to some extent Francis Collins
contributing suggestions in the drafting
quite specific suggestions which means
their names should have been on the
paper yeah let me pull up one quick
example of a suggestion that Farrer uh
added to the document uh this was on
February 17th right the day the proxy
proximal origin was first published
publicly uh he asks Anderson would you
be willing to change one sentence from
it's unlikely that SARS Cub 2 emerge
through laboratory manipulation to its
improbable that stars cup 2 emerged
through laboratory manipulation and then
uh Anderson responds sure no problem and
then as we saw earlier the final
language is much more like uh it's the
there's very low probability that this
let's see the exact uh yeah
um we do not believe any type of lab
I'm probable to it's implausible I don't
know how much the semantics matter but
it seems like it's getting like less and
less likely the more the kind of edits
come in from the top
yeah and uh yeah so there's a process of
Shifting the paper from uh open-minded
discussion of the lab League of the kind
that Christian Anderson talked about in
his testimony to a dogmatic dismissal of
the possibility uh on all cats yeah and
uh as it becomes effectively the foshee
and cookman's View and not the Anderson
view yet it has Anderson's name on it
who is pressuring them to do that there
is one email that refers to the higher
ups wanting this to happen
um there is there are also exchanges
between Anderson and others uh that
there's one that came out just 24 hours
ago in which he says it's freaking well
possible uses the word frigging yeah um
frigging well possible that it did come
out of a lab you know in private
Anderson is doing all the right things
he's raising all these questions and yet
he's the senior author on a paper that
comes out completely dismissing the
possibility there's a little Pangolin uh
thing in here too because during that
week between the first and the 8th of
February
rumors spread that there was an
announcement coming about uh pangolins
uh the bangle announcement was made
by a South China university that they'd
found a very similar uh virus in
banglins and they even said that it was
99 the same and there was great
excitement and uh Francis Collins wrote
to Jeremy Farah and said oh good I
assume it has the fearing oh no does it
have the fearing cleavage site
um and uh by the end of that week they
knew that it did not have the fearing
cleavage site and so there's an exchange
between Anderson and an editor at nature
magazine
in which she says can't you make this
stronger this document can't you
um
dismiss the possibility altogether
because isn't that what we're trying to
do
and surely the pangolins are evidence
for that and he patiently explains to
her now I'm afraid the pangolins don't
really help us here that ongoing pattern
of a the difference between like the
what's put out publicly and these chats
and emails that are happening behind the
scenes one of the most egregious ones
that has come out in recent days that
kind of put a a bow on this section I
think is you know in his opening written
testimony this is what Christian
Anderson says about these final
conclusions that his paper came to by
the time we published our final version
of proximal origin I no longer believe
that cult the culturing scenario was
plausible so that's the scenario where
it was you know sent through issue over
and over in a lab he but at the
beginning he thought it was you know
possible by the end he thought it was
not plausible and that's why they came
to that conclusion well on their
substack uh Matt taibi and Michael
schellenberger uh obtained some of the
slack chats from uh Anderson and some of
his colleagues this is from April 16
2020. this is a month after the final
publication of the paper he tells his
colleague Andrew uh rambaut uh that
here's the issue I'm still not fully
convinced that no culture was involved
if culture was involved then the prior
completely changes because this could
have happened with any random stars like
Cove which there are many I really
really want to go out there gun swing
say don't be such an idiot believing
these dumb theories the Precedence
deflecting from the real problems but
I'm worried that we can't fully disprove
culture we also can't fully rule out
engineering for basic research yes no
obvious signs of engineering anywhere
but that you're Insight could have been
inserted via Gibson assembly I mean that
you know if I were Christian Anderson's
attorney I would be concerned seeing
these two documents right next to each
other
um but I I think
that the committee has established that
there was at the very least a very large
public private Gap and
um
that there was some level of pressure
coming both from our the the top levels
of our Public Health institutions but
also peer pressure from the peer
reviewers who wanted a certain outcome
and I guess the main question is that
that can't really be answered is like
how much of this was you know nefarious
and how much was like confirmation bias
and wanting a certain
outcome that that was just going to be
inevitable with this group of scientists
yeah I mean notice the date on those
last messages April the 16th this is a
whole month after yeah
um proximal origin has been published
two months after it's been drafted and
and far from believing his own paper he
still thinks it's possible that it was a
lab leak yeah and he's not saying that
to the world this is the time when I'm
communicating with him by email and I'm
getting
complete denial of of a lab leak back
um uh and so it you know remember what
what what's the alternative here
what is it that really changed their
minds about publishing any speculation
about a lab leak
it's politics not science in other words
in those three days between the 1st of
February and the 4th of February when
they draft the paper and then in the
days after when they strengthen the
paper
they are concerned about the
implications for science the
implications for relations with China
the implications for
um the uh any Vindication of the Trump
regime Etc that's what's really
bothering them as he says you know in
that last message he says something
about I really want to be able to go out
there and say that the administration's
wrong
um uh yeah the wordings in there
somewhere
um so you know that's that that's the
that's the null hypothesis here that
they change their minds for political
not scientific reasons and it does seem
very persuasive hey thanks for watching
that clip from our conversation with
Matt Ridley about the origins of the
covid-19 pandemic you can watch another
clip from that conversation right here
or the full conversation right here